these strawberry upside down hearts are
a spin on a classic I've always loved
pineapple upside down cake and I wanted
to try making it with strawberries and
heart-shaped for Valentine's Day I start
by slicing strawberries and coating them
with melted butter and sugar I'm using
coconut sugar here then I grease
heartshaped rakins with cooking oil and
assemble the sliced strawberries in each
one slightly fan to maintain the heart
shape now for the cake batter I combine
a flour granulated monk fruit or sugar
baking powder salt then I add in
softened butter and reverse cream by
mixing for a few minutes with the dry
ingredients in a separate Bowl I whisk
the egg with yogurt and vanilla before
slowly adding to the mixer on low speed
until Incorporated next I roughly Cho
strawberries and fold these in before
spooning the batter in the ramkin once
baked I let cool for 5 to 10 minutes
then invert on a cake stand since
strawberries lose some color when
they're baked I make it more vibrant by
brushing a little strawberry jam on top
add a dollop of whipped cream and enjoy